- thank you for more on the president's
calls to mobilize the US military we're
joined by chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett who is also the host of
the takeout and debriefing the briefing
podcast major good morning first off
does the president have the authority to
mobilize the military against protesters
he does in the District of Columbia
because it's a federal city he does not
in any other State of the Union there's
an insurrection act that says if things
get out of control and state resources
are exhausted and importantly governor's
request assistance from the federal
government because something is spun out
of control the president can invoke the
insurrection act but it is a cooperative
arrangement in which governors say my
resources are exhausted I need extra
federal help it has happened before it
happened after the Rodney King riots it
happened after Hurricane Hugo
interestingly this is on the law side of
it not the symbolism or language side
which I think we should get into but on
the legal side the 1981 Reagan Justice
Department concluded that the
insurrection Act does not give the
federal guard but or the president
unlimited powers it has to be done in
concert with governors and right now
governors are saying to the president
you're way out of line so is this
largely a symbolic gesture then do you
think by the president do you think
major what what are the political
implications here no no I don't think
the symbolism is small at all I think it
is enormous and the language is enormous
the defense secretary the United States
yesterday talked about battlespace in
America a battle space and that
helicopter hovering over people who yes
we're violating their curfew but we're
doing so peacefully almost seems like a
conditioning of the military in which it
will orient itself toward peaceful
Americans in their own Street doing
something that doesn't harm property or
people those things are powerful visual
symbols and the language of dominate
battlespace america indicates and
signals to the country exactly what this
president is girding for and you have to
ask yourself what institutions are there
to protect people in the streets and
does the president respect them I think
that is a conversation our country if it
hasn't already had
begin happening in very definite ways
going forward major we heard in wages
report that the president said two
governors if you if you don't confront
the protesters you're gonna be seen this
week they'll dominate you what's been
the reaction to that bike by governors
out there the president looked at the
video this weekend and said America is
running amuck not looking at the
protesters who were saying we have deep
held grievances and we want redress but
only the isolated and look the looting
is real the violence is real
the boarded up businesses in many cities
in America that's real that's not
fiction and that is a problem and it has
to be dealt with and the president is
saying to governors and mayors
if you don't do it I'm threatening to
take over your places he's essentially
saying something that I think he knows
he can't do and probably won't do but he
wants a Clarion of strength to be
associated with his presidency in order
to motivate governors and city mayors to
do something stronger than they've done
before if it works he will bathe himself
in this strength symbolism if it doesn't
the president will have a problem that
he can't solve and that mayors and
governors will feel helpless when their
orientation of the federal government to
solve on their own yeah and there is a
possibility it could backfire major